bonjour nous sommes en direct ce jeu 1
pour un événement très attendu puisque
aujourd'hui débute le jubilé de la reine
d'angleterre un jubilé qui marque les 70
ans de règne d'elizabeth ii et pour en
parler aujourd'hui je suis avec jérôme
bédard journalistes et 6 qui collaborent
à cette revue qui s'appelle dynastique
que j'ai ici merci beaucoup gérant
d'être avec nous merci de votre
habitation avec vous on va parler de ce
jubilé de cet événement qui est en train
de se dérouler qui va bientôt se
dérouler pour l'instant tout est en
train de se mettre en place tout au long
de ce live bien sûr vous n'hésitez pas à
poser vos questions on essaiera d'y
répondre au mieux comme d'habitude je ne
salue d'ailleurs jimmy ou qui nous à
rejoindre le chat qui nous dit qu'ils
nous salue jean fait de même donc
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions on
va essayer de répondre un peu à tous de
parler de
7-2-2 d'elizabeth ii de sa vie de ce que
se représente cet événement et déjà on
parlait de ce jubilé ce jubilé déjà
pourquoi faire un jubilé pour la reine
d'angleterre à ce moment là
faire un jubilé cela permet de marquer
une présence une date
d'inscription à l'histoire et les
anglais sont assez friands de ce type de
commémore de commémoration vivante
puisque ce la reine d'angleterre incarne
le pouvoir politique
malgré les premiers ministres malgré le
toutou la valse des dirigeants quand
elle arrive au pouvoir en 1952
on est encore en pleine guerre froide
elle sort à elle a grandi dans une
angleterre qui était est également une
angleterre coloniale
avec les indes avec et pour les anglais
elle et ne continue une continuité
de pouvoir
ce que nous n'avons donc enfin 52 nous
avons encore vincent auriol c'est sa
première visite avec rené coty elle va
connaître le général de gaulle elle va
connaître tous les présidents jeu
jusqu'à la gécamines et le maquereau est
en fait elle est la plus vieille
institution d'europe
les papes sont passés les prénoms de la
république surpasser et elle reste
indémodable
et finalement elle incarne un pays qui l
a permis le
le monarchie tel quel à l'incarner elle
même comme la reine victoria sont à
grand mère elle avait incarné au 19e
siècle
elle incarne et
du changement
mais dans la continuité
aujourd'hui il ya le c'est le point de
départ de ce jubilé quel est le
programme soit de ceux des festivités
alors le topping tricolore ce qui est
une sorte de 14 juillet en fait pour les
britanniques donc il ya un défilé des
troupes alors le
c'est un défilé un peu un peu plus
c'est différent de bras le rapport des
britanniques à l'armée un peu différent
du nôtre au 14 juillet mais c'est à ça
c'est à peu près l'équivalent du 14
juillet pour
d'ouvrir la même chose d'elle et les
troupes qui vont défiler petit à petit
sur le voile à tous les doutes et
régiment de la garde royale sous
d'ailleurs pas tu sais pas si nombreux
que ça
et
c'est vraiment l'équivalent et 14
juillet pour les français
d'ailleurs ces décors et les
je suis une date
qui est parce qu elle l a succédé à son
père en février 50 2 elle a été
couronnée je crois en janvier eu 53 donc
c'est une date choisie
un peu mais pas de
formalité comme nous le 14 juillet mais
mais il ya vraiment cette
c'est le défilé des troupes parce
qu'elle aussi elle est chef des armées
elle est aussi chef de l'église
d'angleterre
ce qui est pour nous en france ceci
quelque chose de compliqué c'est à dire
que l'angleterre a sa propre église
l'église anglicane et
et depuis le 16e siècle ce sont les rois
d'angleterre qui
incarne aussi l'église proteste on peut
inclure un protestantisme l'église
anglicane
est donc l
un chef politique qu'un chef militaire
et un chef religieux
et c'est ça qui est qu'aujourd'hui elle
va avec tout
voilà on la voit
voilà on la voit avec l'archevêque de
canterbury
elle incarne
une sorte de totalité de la vie publique
anglaise mais parce que on peut quand
même rappeler aussi une reine
d'angleterre qu'elle est quel est son
rôle au sein de hot hot ou au sein des
institutions alors plus qu'un pas voilà
oui alors surtout que pour nous français
nous avons la constitution de 1958 il
n'y a pas de constitution écrite
angleterre c'est à dire que son rôle
politique et lui même le fruit de siècle
d'évolution
les plus grands ayant lieu au 19e siècle
ou pro progressivement les rois d'anglet
et les rois des reines d'angleterre sont
sont eux-mêmes sortie du
du jeu
politicien dire qu'aujourd'hui elle
quand elle fait le discours du trône
qu'elle n'a pas pu faire parce qu'elle
était trop faible il ya un mois et donc
est laissé à son fils son petit fils le
fait d'incarner la la monarchie
tous toutes ces déclarations sont
préétablis avec le premier ministre
en fait
elle a eu moins là le vivre mais son
père qui l'avait plus vécu dire que le
finalement le monarque anglais reprend
ses pouvoirs dans les moments de crise
et on l'a vu sur la seconde guerre
mondiale et depuis
lors d'une
elle a
maintenu une présence mais sans avoir
besoin
de
réinvestir le champ politique elle est
un peu en réserves des institutions
c'est à dire que elle permet une
continuité
et s'il y avait
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que les anglais
aiment beaucoup c'est à dire que
l a vécu la seconde guerre mondiale elle
a vécu les bombardements à londres sont
perles
lui a permis d'être infirmière dans
l'armée britannique
elle a vécu
avec toutes ces moments terribles dit
depuis d'ailleurs ce sont
les feux ne sont pas renouvelés et
encore une différence entre l'angleterre
et la france c'est qu'elle n'a pas eu à
subir la décolonisation puisque
l'angleterre à décoloniser l'un d'eux
dès 1947 et il n'y a pas eu la guerre
d'indochine après la guerre d'algérie
comme nous avons nous avons vécu
donc elle est en la foi l'incarnation et
elle est en réserve des institutions
s'ils se passaient les
d'événement grave heureusement pour les
britanniques ne se sont pas reproduits
depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale mais
c'est vrai que l incarner si aujourd'hui
on s'intéresse autant au jubilé de la
reine c'est qu'elle incarne
finalement
la plus la plus vieille institution
européenne puisque le la monarchie
britannique remonte à des temps
immémoriaux et que la constitution même
qui est une constitution non écrite
provient du moyen-âge la chambre des
communes la chambre des lords sont des
institutions qui n'ont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas évolué depuis le
depuis moyenne depuis le moyen-âge
l'angleterre a subi aussi sa révolution
un siècle avant les français c'est à
dire oh oh oh
17e siècle
moment du règne de louis xiv ou les
institutions britanniques ont été secoué
et où la famille royale a réussi à
reprendre la main sans plus jamais être
contestées depuis quatre siècles alors
là nous avons les images en direct de
londres alors la cérémonie va pas de
départ à démarrer tout de suite tout de
suite mais il y aura un événement qui
sera très attendu c'est l'arrivée au
balcon de deux on espère la reine qui
sera l'événement qui sera scruté puisque
c'est là on va avoir un peu des
indications sur son état de santé oui et
il y à 7 en plus de cette mise en scène
qui est facilitée par la
géographie des lieux
la monarchie anglaise s'est
depuis
king âme c'est le première moitié du 19e
siècle il y a une intelligence
de la mise en situation et le palais
le palais de buckingham permet au bout
de
de l'avenue auquel il est situé 2 de
mettre en situation la monarchie
la famille royale
et de se présenter au peuple
on voit bien toute la différence aussi
avec la france encore une fois puisque
le effectivement l'elysée n'est pas du
tout dans cette situation
géographique d'origine géographique mais
voilà il y a une une intelligence en
fait dès la reine victoria et des listes
deuxième siècle la monarchie anglaise
s'est mise dans la situation où elle est
aujourd'hui d'une incarnation visuel
d'une capacité à se présenter au peuple
qui n'a rien de nouveau là reynolds est
vraiment une conservatrice
qui est très conservatrice n'a fait que
continuer ce qu'avait fait son père son
grand-père
café la reine la reine victoria
auparavant
et
il y a
il y a dans ces événements d'aujourd'hui
à la fois une
nous nous y intéressons parce que
l voilà soixante dix ans de règne pour
nous français ça
ça nous interroge sur nos propres
institutions mais au delà il y à une
fête une
je ne dirais pas une banalisation mais
pour les anglais c'est quelque chose de
très naturel
je salue father qui vient de nous
rejoindre sur ce chat et vous n'hésitez
pas tout au long de sa va poser vos
questions suivra bien évidemment ce ce
défilé ont parlé tout à l'heure de la
durolle de la reine d'angleterre comment
s'est passée sa cohabitation peut dire
avec les différents premier ministre
est-ce qu'il y en a eu où ça s'est mieux
passé moins bien passé alors depuis le
19e siècle la monarchie britannique
ce que nous disions que l'arrêt est
symbolique c'est à dire que elle
s'entretient toutes les semaines avec le
premier ministre c'est à dire qu'elle
est au courant de tout
non seulement en angleterre mais les
rênes du du canada de nouvelle-zélande
d'australie hier qu'elle reçoit des
notes
l'ensemble du monde qui lui permettent
d'avoir une vision très cohérente et une
vision
à long terme
et avec les premiers ministres on ne
sait jamais ce qui se dit puisque les
bien entendu les entretiens ne sont pas
publics mais
elle parle d'égal à égal c'est à dire
que le premier ministre désigné par la
démocratie est elle elle incarne une
institution sur un héritage
est en fait elle est toutes les semaines
elle est en mesure de parler
d'égal à égal sur la
vision du monde quand les britanniques
sur le
sur le les intérêts du royaume uni
et effectivement elle a connu certes il
l'a connu
un nombre de premier ministre
dont 12
mai
elle est en phase ii en sus gens de
force
c'est à dire que
malgré l'onction démocratique du premier
ministre britannique
c'est elle qui est la souveraine qui
incarne l'angleterre et ça
effectivement en france pour beaucoup de
raisons
on a du mal à le halal comprendre
mais elle a été aussi une
à plusieurs reprises et s'est retrouvé
confronté aux questions de
deux guerres en 1981
se retrouve avec margaret thatcher qui
déclenche une guerre avec l'argentine
les troupes britanniques
débarquent aux malouines
après l'armée britannique s'est retrouvé
bien entendu en afghanistan et dans
toutes sortes de missions que la france
a pu
a pu partager mais à chaque
même si
on pourrait croire que c'est le premier
ministre britannique qui
prend toutes les décisions
aucun premier ministre a pris une
décision sans lui en parler sans son
aval quelque part il faut se rendre à la
halle pour avoir son aval implicite à
dire qu'il n'y a pas de pas de prise de
parole mais il ya une discussion et on
peut penser que si elle était en
désaccord sur certains dossiers sur
certains
notamment au plan international elle
pourrait le faire savoir on ne peut pas
penser que la guerre des malouines été
déclenchée par margaret thatcher sans
l'aval de la reine est ce qu'on va
penser pendant que quelques que le
breakbeat a pu aussi être je ne pouvais
pas été gravées sur son aval
de fait elle a probablement émis des
réserves ce soit lorsque la presse
britannique
dit à ce moment-là parce qu'elle est
profondément européenne
parce qu'elle incarne aussi une amitié
franco franco britannique n'oublions pas
cela
l'angleterre a été l'autre en un rival
pour la france mais à partir de la
moitié
[Musique]
du 19e siècle et d'amitié franco
britannique qui s'est construite elle a
incarné elle a incarné de sa première
visite en 1957 elle est reçue par rené
coty à paris jusqu'en 2014 où elle est
reçue par bien entendu par la cheffe de
par françois hollande mais elle met
aussi reçu à la mairie de paris comme le
veut le protocole français elle parle
parfaitement français oui à la l1
rapports avec la france avait assez
proche de la france final on peut le
dire oui elle a une amitié
l'amitié franco britannique s'est forgé
au cours du 19ème siècle s'est incarné
dans la première guerre mondiale dans la
seconde guerre mondiale et même si les
intérêts français les intérêts
britanniques sont différents elle même
parlant parfaitement français contre
nous comprend très bien
et
on peut aller jusqu'à dire que peut-être
que c'est moins vrai aujourd'hui mais il
ya une vingtaine d'années la monarchie
britannique était une monarchie
substitution pour les français le le le
fait
que nos amis britons part toujours du
couple franco allemand mais finalement
le couple franco-britannique est
beaucoup plus vous incarnez notamment
par le fait que
la reine d'angleterre
connaît très bien la france qu'elle
parle parfaitement français et qu'elle
la rencontre tous les chefs d'état
depuis rené coty
voilà elle est là cette relation de
cette relation de proximité en
angleterre est là aussi ils vont on l'a
dit une aura c'est un événement très
important de la haine il est suivi par
énormément d'envié oui parce que les
institutions britanniques encore une
fois il n'y a pas de constitution la
constituante fin il ya une constitution
mais les notes écrites dire que c'est un
ensemble de traditions et elle et le
comment dire la clé de voûte des
institutions
c'est à dire que je devrais problème des
anglais s'ils n'avaient plus droit c'est
qui il devrait se doter d'institutions
de dunes compte
elle incarne elle incarne le pays avec
tous et tous ces changements toutes ces
mutations
elle est là elle est lara et
et il y à ce dépôt historique
si la famille royale est si respectée en
angleterre c'est qu'elle a été toujours
au rendez vous de l'histoire
et elle a su pour la première guerre
mondiale au cours de la seconde guerre
mondiale
être
là quand il le fallait
c'est à dire que l'angleterre est né en
1926 donc elle a 18 ans 44 et les
l'a connu
ces régiments qui vont défiler elle l'a
vu
elle les a vus déjà défilé pour le
défilé de la victoire 1945
c'est là qu'on mesure la longévité de la
de l'aréna matin oui mais qui n'ont
jamais été même supérieur au pape mais
je n'ai
on a eu au moins les gens qui ont 40 ans
en france ont vu passer trois papes ils
ont vu passer qu'une reine d'angleterre
les gens qui ont 80 en france n'ont vu
qu'une vraie d'angleterre et on appelle
ça ils ont vu qu'ils lui et son père
mais finalement elle incarne
une tradition européenne
qui émeut presque supérieur à la
tradition vaticane alors bon sens et
nous sommes catholiques donc on a une
relation au pape qui est aussi très
importante et
équipe qui peut qui peut être une
fidélité
supérieure celle de la reine
d'angleterre puisque finalement aucun
franc parler franco britannique il n'y a
pas de de fidélité mais il y a une sorte
de
deux traditions qui s'est installée ou
fine la reine d'angleterre incarne
un conservant rien conservatisme
européens et même les anglais
effectivement c'est ont retiré les
institutions européennes vous était
entré
doit être un peu compliqué il faudra
plus beau et surtout ils se sont
toujours bien débrouillé pour défendre
leurs intérêts et ça on peut que leur
kate admiratif sur ce travail mais elle
elle ras elle aura vécu non une
angleterre qui sera entré dans le
dans le mur européenne
royaume uni qui sera sorti de
de l'union européenne est finalement
s'il n'y a pas eu peut-être deux on va
dire de choc
une
violence dans la sortie de l'union
européenne c'est que on sait que la
reine d'angleterre nous voyons les
premiers régiments
donc l'accueil royal
commencé à défiler mais finalement ce
qui a rassuré le reste de l'europe c'est
que
le royaume uni reste fidèle à lui-même
et même dans sa sortie de l'europe de
l'union européenne il n'y a pas eu une
violence
qui aurait pu être pour d'autres
vous voyez de la retirer au réel qui vit
qui vient de passer on n'aura pas de
chars de temps classée salaire assez
comment dire des yeux et historique en
bâtir comme
la différence à c'est la différence avec
le 14 juillet c'est claude julié on rend
hommage aux régiments de de l'armée
française en angleterre c'est plutôt les
régions qui rendent hommage à la reine
donc ça c'est donc ils présentent tous
le
meilleur aspect et puis ils ont gardé
enfin les équivalents
pour nous la garde républicaine
des régiments qui sont à la fois
des régiments qui montent la garde dans
les propriétés royales et qui sont
néanmoins
projeté à l'étranger et les différents
régiments qui l'a défilent avec des
uniformes qui nous paraissent un peu
désuet sont aussi des régiments d'élite
qui ont servi en afghanistan
dans lequel la famille royale et les
fils et les petits-fils de la reine ont
servi et il ya une ancrage
d'angleterre maintient par exemple le
patronage de régime en
ski en europe a disparu avec la fin de
l'autriche hongrie avec la fin de deux
monarchies prussienne avec
il y a un rapport
alors pas totalement évacués en france
d'ailleurs puisque le par exemple de
descendre louis-philippe reste les
parrains de semble de régiment on nous
n'avons pas la même le rapport mais le
comte de paris où sa soeur sont les
parrains d'éléments de chasseurs et ce
qui était naturel dans l'europe du 19ème
siècle mais l'angleterre est la seule à
l'incarner ans encore avec l'espagne
effectivement
il ya un rapport
une imbrication très forte entre la
monarchie et et l'armée et le poids
militaire donc comme le rappelait la
plupart tous les enfants de 7 de cette
famille royale ont servi dans l'armée
ils ont servi dans l'armée les fils de
la reine ont servi par exemple au moment
de
la guerre des malouines j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir monter de pouvoir
aller sur une frégate anglaise qui a
fait la guerre des malouines et il ya
une tradition un rapport le prince
andrew brons qui aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de problèmes soit qu'elle ne
reviendra pas mais
met lui-même a servi comme pilote
d'hélicoptère pendant la guerre des
malouines
la reine d'angleterre est le chef des
communes comme nous le prêt dans la
république le chef des armées et elle
est aussi
ce qu'on dit tout à l'heure le chef de
de l'église d'angleterre deux guides
anglicane auquel elle a un rôle
d'un triple rôle un rôle civile qui est
de continuer à converser avec le premier
ministre et à qui elle peut
dire sous sous sous le sceau de la
confidentialité
elle peut dire ce qu'elle pense
sa vision du monde sa vision de l'angle
de l'angleterre sa vision du royaume uni
mais elle est aussi chef des armées et
lé chef de l'église ce qui effectivement
c'est fait beaucoup pour
une personne pour une personne est
en tout cas pas le français ou au moins
la question la question de
l'église étant sorti depuis on a vu très
rapidement ce fameux balcon on voit sur
alors on le voit plus la sueur c'est sur
ces images mais on l'a vu très très
rapidement c'est le balcon sur lequel
devrait apparaître la reine elizabeth ah
oui voilà on le voit tout au fond de
cette image avec les petites broderie
rouge j'en profite pour saluer christian
léon toussaint qui nous saluent valent
pas vu qu'il vous salue aussi n'hésitez
pas bien sûr un poser vos questions sur
la reine d'angleterre on va a peu parlé
de 2,2 de sa vie aussi de du rapport
qu'ont les anglais à sa vie on peut peut
être vous proposer un petit un petit
sujet sur en angleterre sur le folklore
qui a dans les villages puisque tous les
toutous les villages pour ce jubilé font
en sorte de
de se mettre aux couleurs du royaume uni
il ya une vraie il ya une vraie on va
dire aurait amour autour de cela on peut
le dire je pense qu on va regarder ce
sujet on va en parler juste après c'est
un sujet réalisé par françois carpentier
on a accueilli et
pologne
[Musique]
là
voilà vous la devez donc vu ce petit
sujet sur la bourre des petits villages
on peut dire anglais pour 7 pour
elizabeth pour ce pour ce gibier on l'a
dit il ya une vraie ferveur autour de ce
jubilé de la reine d'angleterre en
anglais c'est une ferveur qui ne s'est
jamais démentie et qui qui est très bien
intégré dans la grande bretagne
contemporaine que tu d'une terre de
d'immigration qui est une terre de
brassage des peuples
mais
la monarchie permet d'amortir
voyez ce terme est
d'amortir 7 rapports du citoyen à une
institution en france on demande aux
citoyens d'appartenir à une
une vision républicaine qui est en
grande partie vidé
les avantages de la monarchie pour les
anglais c'est que le c'est une
incarnation
on est sujet de la reine en france on
appartient un projet a une histoire
républicaine
a une idée est là bas on est sujet
d'une personne qui en plus n'a jamais
d'étonner qui n'est jamais sorti
le voyez avec l'espagne la semaine
dernière c'est à dire que le roi juan
carlos qui a permis de retourner
démocratie en espagne et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que
large partie des espagnols le respecte
beaucoup mais il s'inscrit dans une
histoire espagnol très compliqué il n'y
a pas de complication angleterre ils ont
réglé leurs problèmes politiques
internes au xviie siècle avec cromwell
avec
une révolution
qui
plus d'1 plus d'un siècle d'avant sur
notre révolution et qui s'est
terminée sur un consensus autour
d'une fonction royale
ou progressivement les rois et les
reines d'angleterre on
abandonner
la partie la plus visible de leur
pouvoir pour conserver un rôle
symbolique
et est donc
c'est finalement l'angleterre est le
pays le plus stable en europe
et avec le
regard
on va dire insulaires sur sur le reste
de l'europe mais une stabilité du fait
des institutions et on se rend compte
quand on voit le jubilé aujourd'hui
l'importance et 2
et la stabilité des institutions
alors que nous on en a réussi à intégrer
avec la vème république
qui
qui arrive à perdurer parce que
peut-être qu'elle correspond le mieux
[Musique]
à l'idée que les français se font de la
politique les anglais
aujourd'hui personne de sérieux ne
voudrait abolir la monarchie britannique
oui alors justement on va me poser
toutes les questions sur la sur le futur
de la monarchie on avale patuc il dit
malheureusement ce n'est pas en france
que l'on fait une pareille fête si nous
avions une reine alors si je vais parler
de ses plus hauts du sujet de la
fascination qu'il y a en france pour la
reine d'angleterre nous en aurions dû y
renoncer parce qu'on a des outils
statistiques qui nous permettent de voir
ce que les lecteurs lisent par exemple
que ces deux sujets qui marche très très
bien que c'est quelque chose qui
intéresse vraiment les français parce
qu'il ya une nostalgie royal en france
que quand la france a coupé la tête de
louis saez
est là elle a enterré ce côté
cette pérennité que les les britanniques
ont réussi
à perpétuer
la monarchie britannique
parce que en tant qu'institution elle
est incapable est pas capable de faillir
comparer avec l'espagne le carlos a
permis le retour de la démocratie il a
réussi à les gays mais il n'y a plus de
discussion sur la question royale en
espagne qui ne peut y avoir en
angleterre la question tout de même plus
il n'y a pas vraiment de questions qui
se dit est-ce qu'on arrêterait la
royauté est-ce que ça s'arrêterait il ya
eu quelques
moments des scandales par exemple
déjà la reine elle même ne jamais été
éclaboussée et ce ni
finalement son fils tu ne l'as pas été
bon lui il ya un divorce avec diana que
tout le monde a suivi
il ya eu peut-être à ce moment la une
une
des débats mais finalement que prince
charles aujourd'hui il a réussi à
sublimer c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
personne ne remet en cause le fait que
le prince chat
va succéder à sa mère c'est voilà c'est
quelque chose qui lui perd ntv qui mêle
et oblige on pourrait parler d'une chose
c'est son sens son abdication qui est
quelque chose qui c'est une rumeur qui
existe depuis je pense au moins une
dizaine d'années c'est quelque chose
auquel vous vous ne pourrez pas non
parce qu'en fait
la monarchie britannique n'a pas besoin
elle s'est déjà tellement adapté qui n'a
pas besoin de s'adapter
on a pu voir un pape se retirer mais on
fait
ça serait assez contraire
à la vision monarchique des anglais et
en plus ce serait pour elle même qui a
reçu ce sms de dépôt sacré de son père
elle ne peut pas envisager de c'est
comme un député qui ne se représenterait
pas dans ces circonscriptions c'est
c'est on ne peut pas elle ne peut pas
lâcher ses sujets parce que eux-mêmes le
vivrai mal elle elle est là son rôle et
si elles tiennent marché britannique
existe encore c'est parce que elle
répond à une fonction sacrée qui a été
comment dire qui est passé
fac s'est adapté au temps mais mais
elle ne peut pas rompre avec le sacré
effectivement et on est elle avait aussi
déclaré alors j'ai ce discours qui a été
prononcé autres au cap pour ses 20 ans
où elle dit où elle déclare devant tu
tout vent tout ce que ma vie entière
qu'elle soit longue ou courte sera
consacré à vos services et ça c'est l'
indice donné à tout le monde pour dire
voilà je resterait en place quoi qu'il
arrive jusqu'au bout
si la monarchie il ne remplit pas sa
fonction de représentation et
d'incarnation elle n'a plus lieu d'être
donc si la brique et
remettrait en cause
sa propre tradition
différent de la france et même différent
du vatican s'est pas de monarchie
élective les la
part
une chose qui nous paraît au 21e siècle
un peu un peu spécial qui est le
l'hérédité
et c était rééditée qui permet une
stabilisation
n'oublions pas que jusqu'en 1958 la
france a connu une instabilité
permanente aussi
et que nous nous y avons répondu par des
institutions voulue par le général de
gaulle par la vème république
la monarchie britannique a été le moyen
d'amortir
tous les conflits elle a eu des premiers
ministres travaillistes à dire
socialiste et premier ministre 2 de
droite est là
c'est aussi l'avantagé aux monarques
c'est à dire que le marque elle et elle
a été préparée pour cette fonction alors
elle a été préparée sauf que elle
précisément ne l'a pas tant été que ça
puisque son début de règne elle a été
préparée puisqu'elle est toujours dans
une fabuleuse l'éducation en fait la
force de la monarchie c'est que l'enfant
est la petite fille qui a grandi dans
les années 30 et 40 est là dessus depuis
son plus jeune âge qu'elle serait amené
à renier et incarner
leur présentation d'un état
et ça
ça s'appelle un devoir
en fait effectivement elle est arrivée
elle n'avait pas trop
après la mort de son père elle n'avait
pas 30 ans mais elle avait été préparée
c'est la différence entre les
institutions républicaines et
l'institution royale
le seul principal avantage monarchie
c'est que le futur roi ou la future
reine dès son enfance sait qu'il devra
incarner
une histoire une tradition
un ensemble de faits tandis que chez
nous le président sort d'une lutte de
pouvoir
ou finalement
voilà
à l'ena ou dans d'autres écoles il va
déciderez de d'avoir une carrière
politique
à cinq ans le
puisque cinq ans d'ailleurs maintenant
le l'arrière petit fils de la reine
c'est qu' un jour les renards et qu'il
est il a l'obligation
de remplir un certain nombre de critères
de
2,2 emmagasiné ensemble de connaissances
elle est effectivement le le chef d'une
famille royale qui a des moyens qui a
une
richesse et des moyens familiaux énorme
mais
le pacte avec ces sujets c'est qu'elle
n'a pas le choix
elle n'a pas eu le choix
n ont pas pu être actrice halloween à
hollywood elle n'aurait pas pu être
on voit toujours le côté et les ceux qui
critiquent la monarchie le font toujours
en dix ans il n'y a pas de rationalité
démocratique mais en fait il ya
peut-être que c'est beaucoup plus est
probablement beaucoup plus compliqué
psychologiquement d'hériter de la
couronne d'angleterre que telus présent
la république française on n'a pas le
choix les prisons la république
française française on travaille pour ça
on travaille et on menait une carrière
et se sont mis dans une situation où ils
avaient le choix
elle appelle le choix
et c'est probablement
psychologiquement beaucoup plus
compliqué d'hériter
d'un trône
que de conquérir un pouvoir républicain
oui sur lequel sur lequel on a travaillé
pourtant vous l'avez dit c'est quelque
chose qui tombe ce qui est plus celle là
qu'hier c'est ces fonctions-là à ces
jeunes au final oui mais à les préparer
c'est à dire que
de même façon qu'eux vous passez en bacs
à 18 ans elle a 18 ans elle était et est
prête elle n'était pas prête sur
l'expérience mais était prête sur la
tradition c'est à dire que l' avantage
d'une
de ce
sept types de transmission du pouvoir
c'est que
elle elle a
de la vue son père
incarné et en plus dans des moments très
difficiles qui était de seconde guerre
mondiale
lll a grandi dans un
des lieux de pouvoirs dont elle a
répondu à
une incarnation qui
qu'elle n'a pas choisi mais
où qu'elle a été préparée
c'est la différence vraiment avec les
institutions républicaines c'est à dire
que
n a pas fait le choix d'aller au pouvoir
elle n'a pas eu le choix
et ensuite elle s'est inscrite dans une
famille royale qui britannique qui une
intelligence réels tels mm transmise à
son fils
peut se rappeler dans les années 80 où
les années 90 les procès qui a été
commis à son fils son fils qui est
dépassé 70 ans aujourd'hui
incarne quand même une conscience
écologique
une vraie connaissance des relations
internationales ça aussi et puis c'est
lui qui a pris sa place aujourd'hui au
final oui parce que elle n'a pas dit qui
est bien sûr mais son état santé fait
que c'est lui qui finalement qui est en
charge des affaires à sa place
finalement quelque part oui c'est très
logiquement dire que ne se pose pas la
question ne s'est même pas posée
elle n'a pas pu aller se son fils et son
petit-fils qui ont incarné là
la transmission on peut d'ailleurs
penser que si elle n'a pas voulu aller
elle aurait pu prononcer ce discours le
peut-être que ce jour-là elle n'était
pas capable d'avancer sans une canne et
que pour elle même elle veut se
présenter à ces sujets en deux ne forme
physique
96 en parfaite mais c'est aussi tout
leur jeu de voir si elle apparaîtra sur
ce balcon si elle apparaîtra avec une
canne sans canne s'y
faire c'est quelque part aussi pour
avancer sur important là on voit là
alors il faut il faut il faut parler de
la géographie c'est à dire que palais de
buckingham est effectivement très ouvert
sur l'extérieur
le palais de buckingham correspond à ce
qui a été le tube donc qu'on connaît
plus en france mais ce qu'ont été les
tuileries avant leur destruction après
la guerre de 1870 qui étaient très
ouverts aussi sur paris et les français
pouvaient venir dans l'est dans le
jardin donc il ya une mise en scène du
pouvoir c'est ça qui est très
intéressant dans la cérémonie
d'aujourd'hui
c'est que c'est un cette incarnation en
plus elle se met
elle se met elle même en scène
pour incarner au mieux
la tradition monarchique
anglaise est
effectivement buckingham d'ailleurs qui
est un
voilà ce qu est un palais assez austère
sivu un modèle d'ailleurs des
architectures qui a été copié sur
buckingham à paris c'est le quai d'orsay
c'est vous c'est le palais royal de
bruxelles
il ya une austérité très différente du
rapport
que les français sont pures à versailles
ou qu'ils peuvent avoir avec l'elysée
qui est
finalement une
demeure qui ne se met assez peu en scène
oui puisqu'elle est un balcon by ap il
n'y a pas de balcon c'est quelque chose
qui est quand même très dans une petite
rue c'est pas facile accéder alors que
là on est sur un droit qui est
extrêmement ouvert là on voit là une
autre alors là c'est là ce sont les
invités qui arrive tpiy alors j'ai une
autre question sur les invités qu'elles
sont est ce qu'il ya des invités c'est
ce qui est des chefs d'état étrangers
qui font le déplacement mais je ne crois
pas parce qu'en fait le
cette cérémonie est là
elle n'est pas destinée
internationale elle destinée à la vie
politique
interne
du royaume uni
le trouble in the colours le jubilé
c'est un
ça s'adresse aux britanniques
que les
que que les français que l'ensemble des
pays du monde s'y intéresse
c'est
ça rentre dans le
la vision globale de la cérémonie mais
la monarchie ne peut
survivre que si elle s'adresse d'abord
aux sujets aux citoyens britanniques
et c'est ça qui est visé il ya une sorte
de nationalisme qui ne dit pas son nom
très fort
on a
14 juillet on invite maintenant
chef d'état étranger et puis donc pas
maintenant d'ailleurs depuis longtemps
sourds
la république parle au monde comme
le 9 mai poutine parler au monde dans
son défilé de la victoire est là
la monarchie anglaise s'adresse d'abord
aux citoyens britanniques
et c'est ça qui qui est le coeur de la
cérémonie d'aujourd'hui alors que là on
voit justement
ddd soldats alors avec leurs habits
alors pas sur cette image là mais sur
une autre je crois si il ya des
caractérisations ne peut nous là de me
le montrer voilà
est-ce que voilà on imagine la ses
habits folkloriques on peut le dire
cd des agents qui sont qui sont
internationales ou qui sont alors
des régiments de la garde royale sont
des régiments qui est
qui ne sont pas seulement affecté à la
garde de des palais royaux et qui sont
eux-mêmes projeté à l'international
sont les soldats d'élite se sont pas des
soldats l'opérette
même la garde républicaine en fait est
plus
et moi
on va dire ouverte sur les
sur les conflits garde républicaine n'a
pas été envoyé en afghanistan tandis que
les résumant de de la reine de la garde
royale sont envoyées participent à la
vie de l'armée britannique
il reste deux de deux armées en europe
les britanniques et nous
mais ils ont une une
ehpad et ce ne sont pas que des soldats
d'opérette et ils sont ils savent quand
il signe un contrat dans ces régiments
qui peuvent être amenés à défendre les
intérêts du royaume uni sur les théâtres
d'opérations extérieures
voilà et donc il ya à la fois cette
côte et hop et opérettes puisqu'ils ont
conservé le bonnet à poil et nous avons
abandonné définitivement dans l'armée
française dans les dernières décennies
du 19e siècle je vois que le dernier
régiment français a rapporté le bonnet à
poil doit être le premier élément du
génie de versailles et que ça lui est
abandonné vers 1890 pour des raisons de
de fonctionnalités
mais le
les anglais ont besoin de effectivement
d'un garde royal d'avoir mais comme nous
avons garde républicaine et on en
parlait il n'y a pas trop de ces essais
c'est très rassemblée sur le national
mais aussi au site où le tous les autres
pays qui sont proches qui sont alors
voilà elle est aussi également rennes 2
d'australie de nouvelle zélande du
canada alors on va justement montré des
images de or en ce moment c'est assez en
séance et en nouvelle zélande que ça se
passe alors les les images de wellington
qui vont arriver dans quelques temps on
rappelle que est-ce qu'on peut rappeler
justement quel est le rôle de la reine
d'angleterre pour ces pays là le
commonwealth a été le moyen d'amortir la
décolonisation pour les anglais
en conservant pour la plupart des pays
du commonwealth en skate 90% ont
conservé la en angleterre comme chef de
l'état donné que sortie c'est la barbade
dont l'île maurice par exemple sorti
les images qu'on a des valises on dirait
une hollande en direct alors il fait
nuit donc on doit pas non plus
énormément de choses et il y avait il ya
des célébrations dans tous ces pays là
en tout cas oui parce que
s'ils n'ont pas aboli la monarchie
l'australie comme le ghana comme la
nouvelle zélande c'est que il participe
à un réseau mondial d' influence la
reine d'angleterre est aussi le centre
d'un réseau d' influence y compris en
europe là je pense qu'il y assez cousin
roumain ses cousins je sais pas si les
bulgares sont là s'il est là elle a un
réseau familial
qui lui permet de peser
sur la politique européenne
[Musique]
même si on n'y prend pas garde
et et sur la politique mondiale
le canada n'était quand même pas un pays
neutre l'australie n'est pas un pays
neutre l'élu hâtivement diplomatiquement
et sur sur l'influent ce
mondial et elle reste chef de l'état
dans ces pays et voilà est donc
tout à fait toute la subtilité de la
monarchie britannique c'est à la fois de
concentrer son message sur le peuple
britannique
tout en arrivant à conserver un réseau
d' influence mondiale
convoi en nouvelle-zélande
mais elle reste la reine d'angleterre
donc l'héritière d'une tradition qui
remonte à guillaume le conquérant qui
remonte même avant guillaume le
conquérant en première ronde angleterre
elle et elle est à la fois
pleinement chefs d'état britannique est
à la tête d'un réseau mondial
que la monarchie dont le système
monarchique a permis une survie plus
qu'une survie
voilà bon la france a tenté de créer la
francophonie
garder des relations avec les anciens
pays colonisés
mais elle le fait naturellement
mais c'est quelque chose qui est inscrit
on va dire dans la
dans l'ordre des choses pour pour le
plein d'amateurs voilà et c'est ce qui
permet à
au royaume uni et à l'angleterre 2
d'avoir un rôle mondial dont toute une
histoire puis c'est une force nucléaire
même si elle est moins indépendante que
nous
puissions plus soumise au code
au système américain
b elle elle incarne alain parce qu'elle
incarne à l'intérieur ça lui permet de
rayonner
sur la scène internationale a dit sur la
scène nationale aussi effectivement on
peut aussi parler peut-être alors je
vais passer à un autre sujet alors pas
sur l'intervalle mais sur l'amour qu'il
portait à la reine d'angleterre par des
gens qui collectionnent parce que
forcément c'est aussi une
manne de revenus pour la pour la
couronne d'avoir justement beaucoup de
petits comment dire goodies on va dire
pour pau pour utiliser dans mutisme et
je dois je voudrais vous proposer ce
petit sujet avec des collectionneurs
comme margaret tyler qui collectionne un
peu tout et qui essayent de voix qui se
montre comme première collectionneuse de
deux petits goodies de la reine
d'angleterre je vous laisse voir ça
eyes wide
shut
[Musique]
photo
anne
lacaud in their de personnes
[Musique]
princio
ap
happytime tigana ou leur famille
[Musique]
voilà pour ce sujet sur les petits
goodies sur les sirops l'amour qu'est
internet on l'a dit aussi tout à l'heure
la la fin de la monarchie en angleterre
n'a pas l'air d'être pour bientôt en
tout cas en mai un nom mais
en fait tout
l'intelligence de la monarchie
britannique actuel provient la reine
victoria qui a anticipé
tous les paradoxes toutes les les les
contradictions qui pourraient surgir
effectivement il était bon ton il ya
vingt ans de ceux de penser que la
monarchie britannique était fatigué a
déjà on le voit que ces collectionneurs
de goodies incroyable que
il ya une vraie ferveur populaire
mais cette ferveur populaire s'inscrire
en plus sur une tradition
institutionnelle
sur une
réunion mondiale
juste on parle de 2 mondial et jouer il
faut coupe tu connais ces images qui
nous viennent en direct de wellington
qui nous permettent de voir un peu ce
qui sait ce qui s'y passe est de
constater le fait que à l'international
aussi pour les pays proches de la
couronne c'est la reine d'angleterre est
très respecté et ils ont fait une
cérémonie en pleine nuit pour saluer ce
jubilé line wii ware chorale
effectivement
dans un monde où le tout avance très
vite où tu as tout avance de plus en
plus vite
[Musique]
la stabilité institutionnelle que
représente l'angleterre un côté
rassurant
quatre coins du globe
et coûté
7,7
[Musique]
d'antan et
kg
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils sont là
[Musique]
voilà pour cette chorale qui avait lieu
en nouvelle zélande à wellington
puisqu'on l'a dit pays proches forcément
de la reine d'angleterre et du royaume
uni on va repartir du coup du côté de
l'angleterre où le défilé continue de se
dérouler trooping the colour sait on l'a
dit au début de réponse at-elle de
redire c'est un événement qui a lieu
chaque année en fait ce chaque année
c'est l'équivalent de notre 14 juillet
donc c'est le défilé des troupes de
soissons - martial et plus débonnaire
que que chez nous puisque
l'angleterre à cultiver
peut-être plus que nous le
le
les traditions
régimentaire
et c'est aussi pour la reine
le moment où elle révise sa famille elle
a réuni ses amis c'est une femme
d'amitié est toujours très heureuse de
retrouver ses amis et de retrouver aussi
la société la bonne société britannique
qui continuent à vivre dans un
dans un monde aristocratique
qui nous parvient bien étranger mais et
pour lequel les titres d'honneur
la fréquentation de buckingham demeure
un
socle
celui-ci vise à sionnel important et
bien entendu le proximité avec
avec le peuple dans son ensemble mais
rien n'est laissé au hasard
à tous les niveaux et toutes les strates
cette journée a un
sens
et peut-être que le plus grand sens et
va être justement l'incarnation la
continuité avec son fils avec son petit
fils avec son arrière petit fils
il ya une mise en scène qui permet
à la monarchie britannique de ceux de se
projeter dans l'avenir
alors qu'on voit les troupes qui
commença
à se placer pardon excusez moi sur 7 sur
cette place qui est située à quelques
centaines de mètres de de buckingham
palace à côté du saint james park lake
juste juste à côté et en fait cessé et
ses troupes vont se stationner j'imagine
sur cette place tout au long de ce
défilé tout à fait effectivement les
différents relais alors de loin en fait
on ne distingue pas forcément fait qu'il
ya au moins quatre ou cinq régiments
différents qu'on reconnaît à la couleur
du plu mais sur leurs bonnets à poils le
puits mais cette petite tâche qui était
voilà enfin cette voie là ça comme ça
tout à fait ouï dire que l'uniforme
reste
uniforme de la pour les troupes à pied
de
pour les cavaliers c'est la même chose
mais ferme du 19e siècle mais on
reconnaît à l'époque l'ensemble des
régiments emporté cette veste rouge
qu'il traditionnelle dans l'armée
britannique est là la différence entre
les différents
régiments qui montent la garde à tour de
rôle autour de buckingham se fait
notamment au niveau du plu mais puisque
les régiment écossais un régime en
irlande et
voilà on peut les spécialistes de
l'uniforme aux logiques reconnaîtront
les différents régiments mais c'est vrai
que on a l'impression que partout ce
même uniforme mais en fait ils se sont
le produit de différents régiments alors
on va pas se répéter un peu mais c'est
parce que j'en ai une question de dates
de la nahda d'auditeurs qui me demande
est-ce que bach roy qui a été invité au
jubilé de la reine non parce que comme
je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est une cérémonie offerte au peuple
britannique
et
kiki et la cérémonie centrale du
monarque de la reine avec son peuple
donc il n'est pas dans la tradition
britannique de d'ouvrir comme nous
n'ouvrons 14 juillet de plus en plus
attention là peut-être moins ouverts
mais c'est pas
la portée symbolique est d'abord envoyé
au peuple lui-même
et c'est une conversation entre le
monarque et ses sujets
c'est le principe même de l'incarnation
anarchique est en fait une des
invitations à l'étranger viendrait
perturber ce rapport direct que la reine
veut conserver avec ces sujets alors
christian toussaint qui nous dit que les
bonnets sont faits en poil d'ours alors
je sais pas si tout avait
tout à fait c'est les bonnets qui ont
été aussi en usage dans l'armée
française comme je le disais tout à
l'heure jusqu'aux années 1890 mais que
les britanniques en ont conservé tout en
rappelant on l'a fait aussi également
tout à l'heure mais que ces régiments
sont amenés à servir
par exemple en afghanistan ce ne sont
pas seulement des régiments d'opérette
mais qu'ils ont
une fonction centrale d'alarmé l'armée
britannique et c'est une sorte de
délégation des régiments qui eux mêmes
sont appelés à servir
sur l'ensemble de la planète et à être
projeté puisque
la grande bretagne est avec la france
l'armé la plus solide
en europe et qu'elle a maintenu ses
traditions militaires comme la française
a maintenu et
les régiments de la garde royale sont
ont dans leurs fonctions de garde et les
palais
de buckingham windsor son mari gamme
mais ils sont aussi amenés dans leur
carrière personnelle ses soldats a
incarné le
rôle opérationnel
sur l'ensemble de la planète on voit la
cavalerie qui
qui arrive toujours dans ce style assez
historique au final les lavis garde
alors oui
une tradition alors faut pas oublier que
les britanniques sont aussi les
héritiers une partie des royaumes
allemand de hanovre et dans leur rôle
alors
dans la cavalerie on retrouve à
santander de
l'héritage de
l'armée allemande du 10ème siècle
uniforme au logis
autant les
couleurs rouge et
la couleur historique de l'armée
anglaise mais les régiments de la garde
royale on voit des uniformes qui ont été
supportés en france et la cavalerie elle
vient plutôt d'un héritage allemand
la reine d'angleterre n'oublie pas que
qu'elle a qu'à un rôle européen et
malgré le break si tu m'inspires et
la projection naturel de l'angleterre
sur les terres du globe elle a un regard
continue d'avoir un regard sur le sur la
politique européenne est sur le
dessus sur le
sur l'histoire de l'europe parce que le
break site n'est que
mais qu'un épisode
du long
longue histoire
compliquée entre le royaume uni et
les pays continentaux alors sûr c'est
sur ces images on voit des gens avec des
avec des ied et les costumes différents
alors ils sont tous en rouge sauf acquis
et qui en jaune est ce que vous savez
pourquoi oui alors
en tête en fait
ce qu'on aurait pu en france on
appellerait des héros d'armes
ce sont
celles là comment dire le
décorum de la monarchie
et représente 6 sont en tête c'est pour
rappeler que l'armée est
aussi
l'armée royale et pour inscrire ce lien
entre le pouvoir symbolique que
représente la monarchie et et l'armée
britannique donc ce sont des
effectivement des fonctions
honorifique souvent confiée à d'anciens
officiers de valeur
et ils
sont le lien entre la souveraine et
l'armée
alors que dans les commentaires beaucoup
de nos de nos commentateurs discutent de
des poils d'ours en disant que font les
associations de protection des animaux
ce n'est pas le sujet du jour nous n'en
parlerons pas malheureusement il ya
aussi tous ces drapeaux qui sont le long
de cette route comme on peut le voir
c'est surtout les drapeaux des pays du
commonwealth c'est exactement
la reine tient à rappeler qu'elle n'est
pas seulement le chef de l'état
c'est un équilibre permanent
l'angleterre entre
royaume uni entre le le discours envoyé
à la population et celles envoyées
outre-mer
puisque le 6ème du commonwealth a permis
à l'angleterre de décoloniser sans
perdre ce réseau d' influence
exceptionnel
c'est similaire un moment à ce qu'a pu
être empire français mais
voilà et effectivement il ya toujours
même si 90% du message est là pour
conforter on n'imagine pas la reine
d'angleterre
si elle n'était plus reine d'angleterre
ne
dirigerait plus de pays mais il ya
toujours ce petit rappel de ce qui fut
et pour les anglais ce qui est très
important aujourd'hui c'est que la reine
d'angleterre a connu le pire des indes
sont le l'oncle de son mari était vice
roi des indes elle a vécu elle a vu la
décolonisation de l'inde du pakistan
elle a suivi les dossiers sur l'afrique
du sud elle est la vraie elle a vécu
tout ce qu'un européen a pu vivre depuis
1940 ça aussi
pourquoi
aujourd'hui
donnez vraiment hâte à
continuer à incarner
cela la monarchie n'a de sens que si
elle
rend service et aujourd'hui
ce que montrent ces drapeaux ce que
montre
cette chorale quand vous voyez en
nouvelle zélande il ya quelques minutes
c'est que la monarchie a permis au
royaume uni de conserver une place
de premier plan sur la politique
internationale par ce biais
c'est pas le seul la preuve c'est que la
france conserve aussi une influence
mondiale mais
la vraie garantie de la survie de la
monarchie anglaise c'est qu'elle permet
aux anglais de continuer à se projeter
sur la scène mondiale alors une petite
question d'adrien mais je sais pas si
vous pourrez répondre qu'ils demandent
quels sont les critères de sélection des
chevaux montés par la hausse or ce bois
là je se dépasse un peu mes compétences
mais
je pense que c'est un système de
2,2
oui de reproduction équestre comme la
france là avec son régiment monter la
garde républicaine donc je pense qu'ils
ont un certain nombre de critères
le terme d'animaux ce qu
on sait à peu près ce que ce que va
donner un
dire un poulain
c'est pas
c'est pas un problème je pense pas
qu'ils achètent leur leurs chevaux à
l'extérieur je pense que j'en doute une
poly gestion de
quelques jours déjà
c'est elle qui va mal on essaie de
répondre à toutes vos questions mais
pour n'a pas parfois toute la réponse et
ce n'est pas grave puisque nous ne
savons pas tout non plus surtout sur un
sujet comme ça qui effectivement au
final le jubilé d'arnaud wauters parle à
la fois on a on a on a l'aspect
historique l'aspect géopolitique c'est
quelque chose qui est assez enfin
l'aspect militaire de 2,2 de défense ça
regroupe quand même énormément de thèmes
pour seront pour cette personne qui on
l'a dit la haine angleterre qui a
déploie hors norme quelque part qui gère
beaucoup de choses différentes dans ce
pays oui à la langue maternelle est à la
fois la chef d'une famille une famille
qu'elle veut voir prospérer
donc très attentive à sa descendance
elle est aussi un chef d'état qui comme
on l'a dit
de par sa longévité et de par son réseau
est une des personnalités les plus
informés peut comparer à peu près au
pape c'est à dire que
la monarchie britannique un réseau
d'information
la république française aussi mais elle
même a emmagasiné un
une somme de connaissances
que peu de personnes
peuvent peuvent avoir sur la planète à
canal ce qu'il y a dont seulement la
capacité à recevoir des informations de
toutes parts mais aussi très grande
force et c'est là où elle fascine toute
la planète ce que depuis
90 ans elle a emmagasiné
savoir
incomparable encyclopédie complète du
cycle au public
et est qu'elles acceptent homme
un convoi est en train d'arriver je
pense qu'on peut le voir sur lui alors
pas sur ces images là mais un convoi qui
est en train d'arriver peut-être pourra
les boutiques apple est longue est
effectivement les arrivées pour voir
quels qu'ils valaient alors on a vu
d'ailleurs sur les images dès que le
convoi passe tout le monde se lève pour
essayer peut-être d'apercevoir fête qui
aura la reine dedans peut-être un autre
membre de la donnée de la famille aurait
mis son entourage et aussi toute la
classe politique britannique mais
entendu qui est invité
la reine est au coeur des institutions
donc
ces dates enfin les lords les députés
britanniques sont bien entendu
invités
aussi penser qu'elle est qu'elle a
convié
le personnel des grandes associations du
pays
elle est aussi très attaché au
patrimoine
donc il ya tout un
garden party comme on a pu connaître en
france jusqu'à récemment
dans toutes les forces vives de la
nation sont sains sont invités
et
bien voir tout au delà au delà il ya
vraiment un message qui est envoyé à la
fois
à ses proches
o o l'ensemble des britanniques et au
monde mais centré sur
sur l'avenir du royaume uni
et le commonwealth lui-même et
des anglais nous dirait pas ne voudrais
pas ça mais en fait les pères est
organisée pour servir enfin pays une
famille
après il ya alors là qui la garde montée
qui va pas parler d'un premier qu'on le
voit sur ces images et les autres
devraient arriver ensuite petit à petit
pour remplir celles 16,7 grande place
qu'on a sur ces images là comme on l'a
dit avec
dédé des hommes à pied ou à cheval il
faut se souvenir que dans l'est
quand elle quand elle avait encore des
possibilités physiques de le faire là la
reine elle-même monter à cheval à la
tête des troupes
en amazone dehors et
à shaktoi copine de colloques donc
ce jubilé prend tout un
décor décorum et une importance cette
année mais c'est une cérémonie qui se
passe tous les ans c'est l'équivalent de
notre 14 juillet et la reine quand elle
était encore physiquement capable de
monter à cheval
bien entendu était
avec ce rôle de chef des armées à la
tête de ces de ces régiments qu'on voit
défiler et qu'on voit parader au sens
premier du terme
aux abords de buckingham donc c'est pas
une cérémonie exceptionnelle c'est une
cérémonie annuelle qui pour nous relever
enfin des aspects particuliers cette
année mais
qui est une série très rôdée très calé
autant que peut l'être notre notre 14
juillet
ce qui n'empêche pas que les troupes et
répété avant comme les troupes
françaises répète le 14 juillet mais
ses 70 ans de john de règne donne
une
une aura particulière
mais cette cérémonie a lieu chaque année
et chaque année les britanniques sont
heureux de se retrouver autour de leur
souveraine
et autour de ces traditions
qui sont
centrales c'est la journée où le peuple
se retrouvent autour de risma souveraine
et comme un cas d'école comme de 14
juillet c'est donc cette année les
festivités du jubilé de la reine ont
duré pendant quatre jours il y aura par
exemple une grande parade alors
justement on va vous montrer un petit
sujet sur une grande parade qui aura
lieu ce week end sur un an ce n'est pas
militaire cette fois ci ce sera plus tôt
il ne parlera de les associations et
avec des symboles qui est qui qui sont
importants pour la reine on va voir
justement il y aura des chevaux et des
korgis je vous laisse voir ce sujet
19 heures
en avant la mi
carême
auj
voilà pour ce sujet sur la parade qui
aura lieu ce week-end sur les
préparatifs des deux parades on va
revenir au
défilé militaire qui a lieu en ce moment
les troupes se met en place ensuite tu
auras la famille royale qui va
apparaître au balcon qui hélas par
l'aplomb le plus attendu il y aura aussi
la royal air force qui va passer un peu
comme notre armée de l'air pour le 14
juillet ils vont passer et faire une
petite fresque on va dire oui il va là
comme on disait tout à l'heure l'armée
britannique restait à la dernière grande
armée d'europe occidentale avec la
france et donc donc selon ses
différentes composantes
marine
l'armée de l'air
armée de terre
est à l'honneur
alors la reine d'angleterre n'invite
presque plus à buckingham puisque les
plus tôt retirer au château de windsor
qui ce qui est une constante chez elle
puisqu'elle a toujours aimé le terroir
britannique elle aime beaucoup aller
à sandringham aussi un en écosse
une passion de la campagne de ce savoir
vivre
britannique
est à la fois d'un déchet compte qu'on
disait un des chefs d'état les plumes
mieux renseignés de la la planète est à
la fois un des chefs d'état qui est le
plus attaché à
un terroir et
à une des paysages
là encore c'est très différent on
imagine mal le président la république
française passé ce week-end en
haute-marne
pour vous ou dans le cantal
alors que la reine d'angleterre prend
passe la plupart de son temps en dehors
de londres
maintenant mais elle a tout mais mais
mais mais mais mais la cultiver c'est ce
ce goût pour
pour les régions
les différentes composantes du royaume
uni est resté très laid donc le palais
de buckingham reste un symbole très fort
mais en fait elle est résident de très
peu très peu maintenant effectivement
après on peut lui dont on peut penser
que c'est comme un premier ministre et
un président à prix d'or en france sauf
que le président prend toute la place
alors qu'en angleterre c'est plus
séparés
oui
c'est très différent nous donnons de
constitution écrite comme les deux par
exemple les états unis mais la
constitution britannique n'est pas
écrite c'est un ensemble
de traditions
sur lequel on ne peut pas transiger mais
mais qui ne sont pas formalisés dans un
texte il n'y a pas un rapport n'est pas
de cour constitutionnelle alors attendez
je crois que c'est là
peut-être les pelouses du prince de
galles
en tout cas les landes au delà de
famille royale
oui si les images
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
j'ai plus de chances de gamme et meghan
markle qui n'ont pas brûlé
les pousses de
ce qui ne devrait pas être présente non
plus au moins il ya une rupture au
balcon du seuil de rupture politique
pas se mettre en dehors des devoirs la
monarchie ne subsiste que parce qu'elle
impose à à la famille régnante des
devoirs question on ne peut pas pourtant
les
dons toute personne
d désireux de nous
désireuses d'échapper aux obligations
de la famille royale ne peut plus faire
partie
sinon la monarchie n'a plus de sens si
les des petits-enfants de la reine
d'angleterre deviennent des citoyens
comme des autres il n'ya plus
justification il est surpris je veux
plus faire partie
de deux atlantique 2 et familiale et on
se rappelle ce qu'on a appelé les
retrouver le terme j'avais noté ici le
m'excite qu'on me regarde corps meghan
markle ea et harry était ressorti
finalement de la couronne et qui dit du
coup une fois qu'on en sorte on ne peut
plus y
revenir c'est comme si on démissionner
d'un poste cette fronde démissionne de
la royauté fiel voilà et c'est pas
possible bien que la royauté n'a plus de
sens si le devoir les plus accomplis et
de voir implique de ne pas avoir une
liberté
on voit toujours le
côté
positif mais on
et aussi un côté négatif c'est à dire
que fait mme royal ne s'appartient pas
elle appartient au peuple
pour ça doit être
doit renoncer à sa liberté personnelle
pour incarner
quelque chose qui la dépasse
d'arrivée adrien qui dit que le capital
le canton est une très belle région plus
variés d'ailleurs que les abords du
palais le rennais route ou qui pensent
que c'est un message pour vous réveiller
le maquereau j'imagine j'aime beaucoup
le cantal bon alors je vais citer c'est
que je le connais bien ce département au
département
beaucoup d'amis là on a vu rapidement
simplement et voilà donc il a le
mondial la disposition militaire est en
train de se mettre en place mais petit à
petit et bientôt arrivera la famille
royale à ce balcon l'événement qui est
rappelons-le il ya aucune spécificité
cette année c'est les mêmes
[Musique]
comme le clae chaque 14 juillet se
ressemble chaque 14 juillet
nous intéressons plus cette soupe into
the colour parce que le symbolise le
jubilé de la reine mais il répond en
fait une
à une tradition et
une habitude qui sur
liste chaque année et que les anglais
partagent chaque année
même si nous nous voyons ça de d'assez
loin
en france oui parce qu'on l'a dit c'est
rationnel mais là c'est les 70 ans et
voilà si
elle voulait 70 ans de règne en terme de
symbole x or cela ressemble au règne de
louis xiv coude ou de la reine victoria
qu'elle a déjà dépassé par la longueur
de rennes mais on est sur un
règne
historique au plan civilisationnel c'est
à dire qu une personne qui a vécu
des anglais
après la mort de la reine ont beaucoup
de mal à
dépasser
elle les a accompagnés depuis la fin de
l'empiré britannique jusqu'à
jusqu'au break site soit 170 en dix ans
de règne quand même choquant
effectivement se rende compte de ce que
ça de ce que ça représente forcément
c'est il y a que les rênes des rois
français pour pour atteindre la même
importance on le voit en espagne juan
carlos
dans une tradition d'ailleurs familiale
à renoncer au trône
donc les l'espagne ne peut pas se
comparer le tri shanghai a sombré en
1918 il reste
des trois bastion du conservatisme comme
on disait à paris en 1914 reste là la
chambre des lords grand état major
allemand et l'académie française
nous assistons ici à
dernière démonstration du conservatisme
et de
du rayonnement de l'europe à une époque
où
le sort du monde se joue au père l'océan
pacifique entre les états unis et la
chine
le jubilé de la reine d'angleterre
permet à l'europe
de dire qu'elle existe encore
60 70 ans de règne pour pour l'art et
membre de terre la reine isabelle c'est
un record
oui c'est un record alors qui est permis
par l'échangé les longévité
actuelle elle est le fait que nous
visons plus en plus vieux
et c'est tant mieux ça a été aussi le
fait que son père est mort prématurément
et la mort subite de son père qui aurait
pu peut encore vivre une vingtaine d'une
trentaine d'années
l'a fait rentrer dans ce même façon que
louis xiv doigt la longévité de son
règne à la mort de son père quand il
était enfant donc il ya aussi ce fait
d'une mort prématurée qui permet de
faire 70 ans on sait bien que son fils n
y aura peut-être 10 ans 15 ans
selon voilà effectivement et puis après
il y aura acquis qui est qui qui en
deuxième il ya pas de will i am all
williams excusez moi dans l'expective
mari n'ont pas pu taille et je crois que
ce qui lui permet de garder une vraie
sérénité et on
voit là on a tous suivi les événement
dramatique la mort de sa belle-fille
ces cas aujourd'hui la monarchie est
assurée que le
fils de william est là pour
80 ans et elle voit presque à coucher la
monarchie du 22e siècle
elle qui a qui a grandi dans les
souvenirs de la reine victoria
donc qui a grandi avec elle a connu des
gens qui
incarnent et la monarchie britannique au
19e siècle elle est déjà dans le 22e
siècle
et c'est ce qui nous ce qui nous fascine
si on regarde aujourd'hui
cet événement c'est parce que ça nous
ça nous ça nous renvoie à la fois à
notre histoire
et ça nous projette dans un avenir
oui effectivement et puis je vous
rappelle vous pas vous êtes actuellement
très nombreux très nombreux à nous
suivre christian toussaint qui nous dit
que c'est un grand plaisir cette
retransmission merci à vous de nous
suivre effectivement vous n'hésitez pas
à poser vos questions c'est sur ce
balcon un peu plus tard que la famille
royale va apparaître on verra qui est là
si la reine d'angleterre et là quelle
sera son attitude puisqu'il y avait des
interrogations sur son état de santé on
le rappelle oui oui toute personne de 96
ans la veille on ne peut pas savoir si
elle sera en état le lendemain est donc
en état de de paraître mais je crois
quand même elle a une force personnelle
qu'elle a concentrées sur cet événement
il est probable qu'après elles prennent
beaucoup de repos qu'elle
on a vu qu est la même elle a même
plutôt que d'apparaître fatigué
au discours du trône et d'autres
cultures du parlement elle a préféré
délégation fils
elle reprend comme elle représente elle
ne peut pas se permettre et elle est en
même temps ou au delà même de la
fonction elle a une vision d'elle-même
où elle ne veut pas apparaître devant
ses sujets fatigué
faible favorable en mai vulnérables voir
elle incarne comme son père a incarné la
résistance britannique entre 1940 et
1944 comme elle même a incarné le
rayonnement de la grande bretagne depuis
70 ans
alors c'est ce n'est pas l'or n'était
pas chef d'état cela il faut rappeler
qu'il ya encore un chef d'état en vue de
la seconde guerre mondiale qui est le
l'ancien roi de bulgarie enfin le roi de
bulgarie
surtout les premiers ministres et il
sait le dernier est un cousin la reine
d'angleterre et qui effectivement le
dernier souverain
chefs d'état de la seconde guerre
mondiale donc elle elle n'a pas connu un
second derby en tant que chef d'état
c'est son père mais elle l'a connu
physiquement elle était infirmière elle
à
ses parents avaient décidé de rester à
londres sous les bombardements
de partager
la dure vie des britanniques sous les
bombardements allemands
et l'unc elle incarne cela pour les pour
les pour les britanniques et c'est très
important
ça
là où aujourd'hui elle doit être
heureuse
du travail accompli c'est que
effectivement elle va permettre elle a
permis
elle va permettre la transmission
de la couronne
aujourd'hui son fils le prince charles
est
très apprécié des anglais
c'est un prince sont très modernes
très très au fait des problèmes
d'écologie
et qu'antoine de la planète et
peut-être que sa plus grande fierté
près toutes les tourmentes qu'elle a pu
connaître c'est qu'aujourd'hui son fils
est apprécié et va hériter d'une
couronne en son temps elle peut encore
dire quand il le méritera parce que
c'est ce qui arrive c'est à dire la
caisse devrait hériter d'une plus grande
affirmé confirmés et
avec
héritiers de deux principes
qu'elle a toujours voulu voulait
incarner qu'elle a voulu transmettre et
même l'élection de son petit fils et son
arrière petit fils il y aura cette
imprégnation comme il y eut cette
imprégnation de la reine victoria dont
on parle encore et on parlera d hab et
deux îles c'est vrai que c'est se dire
que la venue sur son premier voyage
officiel en france en 1957 son dernier
en 2014
c'est quand même
une longévité
incroyable pour pour nous qui avons eu
l'habitude de changer de président très
souvent effectivement adrien 44e qui non
c'est le prince andrew sera-t-il présent
sur le balcon qu'on tue ses démêlés
judiciaires
a priori non il ne devrait pas être
présent il est peu probable qu'il y soit
après il faut comprendre que la
monarchie c'est un souverain c'est pas
la famille est accessoire
elle peut bannir son fils son petit fils
s'ils ne remplissent pas les critères
de respect des traditions et du
dub reggae qui avait la common decency
c'est pas grave
elle incarne alors sa famille est scruté
mais
c'était son père avant elle et ça sera
son fils après le reste n'a pas de temps
d'un point ils sont
ils peuvent être évacués
sans que cela pose un problème ce n'est
pas une c'est pas une famille au sens
prévaricatrice
est elle-même sans renier ses enfants
que ses petits enfants et l'affection
que toute mère peut avoir pour son fils
ou pas son petit fils elle est prêt à
sacrifier politiquement toute personne
qui mettrait en danger
la l'image l'image de la royauté
conçu comme un
[Musique]
service d'ailleurs les gens ont peu
compris son rapport avec diana c'était
lui qui était compliquée parce que on
regardait se regarder ça avec un prisme
humain de famille on peut dire oui et
alors que il faut pas oublier que c'est
un rôle politique et qu' elle ne peut
pas se permettre
elle n'est là et ses enfants et ses
petits enfants ne sont là que parce
qu'ils incarnent un pouvoir politique
symbolique
qui ne peut pas se permettre
lieu faute
dans les commentaires un an tu as donc
un kit qui n'a pas de solution de
prouver qu'ils nous parlent de la fin du
règne de l'ambiance dans la famille
royale est ce que les membres de l'union
m entre cent tandis que les habitants
des bons rapports avec avec visiblement
oui l als ont son défunt mari ont
toujours
tenu à
entretenir des liens même avec les
autres d'ailleurs les autres familles
royales
parfois ça a été assez paradoxal parce
que on sait que la politique anglaise a
été compliqué que ils ont sacrifié un
certain nombre de leurs cousins en
yougoslavie on manie
ils ont été obligés de céder à des la
realpolitik et elle a toujours su
distinguer
sa vie personnelle
donc de quel d'ailleurs à le voeu
qu'elle conseille de rester dit
certaines réserves autant que je peux
l'être une famille s'y exposer et de le
coter la fonction politique
c'est pas l'angleterre n'est pas un
royaume d'opérette
on est sur une puissance
principales puissances mondiales même si
comme comme la france nous n'avons plus
le
le même rôle et le même poids c'est une
puissance qui est la force de frappe
qui
kiki calais détient le nucléaire et qui
comme on vous le disait avec la france
la dernière arme et d'europe donc ce
rôle politique
[Musique]
impose
soit intraitable avec sa propre famille
du moment que cette famille n'étaient
pas entièrement dévoué à la cause
britannique
servi par la famille royale on a vu très
rapidement dans les tribunes boris
johnson qui était présent est ce qu'on
sait aussi boris johnson commence et ses
rapports alors on en a pas et du
appareils du pasteur que ce soit sur
bruce johnson derrière ses côtés
détonnant et un est un enfant de la
gentry britannique
donc il a dès son enfance lui-même a
totalement intégré ses codes
son rapport avec la la reine est
totalement cadré par cette constitution
donne écrite qui est celle du royaume
uni mais lui-même en plus à c'est aussi
une différence avec la france nous
n'avons les anglais en faire leur
révolution xviie siècle et elles sont
très différentes donc les premiers mini
sont sous eux même presque préparer à 7
à cette relation
qu'ils vont avoir
avec la reine puisque chaque semaine le
premier ministre entretient avec la rave
il est très conscient et il est très
respectueux de l'institution
donc donc
malgré les tourments
qu'il connaît aussi venu
du parti conservateur aujourd'hui
leur règne qui connaît ses qualités
parce que mme johnson à quelqu'un de
talentueux
je pense que leur visiblement leur
relation en tout cas son
sont très
à la fois très codifié et à la fois
avec une sincérité dans les échanges
et un respect de du premier ministre
pour dassault vannes on va vous voulez
on va vous laisser vivre un peu ces
images de défilés qui ont débuté et on
vous en reparlera
[Musique]
non
oh
oui
[Musique]
oh
bon
[Musique]
non
là
on
[Musique]
et donc voilà vous suivez alors c'est
pas sur ces images là mais sur les
images de la
dépouille à forte et continue on a
remarqué la présence de déco c'est
possible oui bah la reine est très
attaché à l'ecosse et ça va être un des
gros dossiers britannique dans les
années qui viennent ce qui est une
projection sur un nouveau référendum les
écossais voulait rester majoritairement
dans l'union européenne dont ils ont
très mal vécu le mexique est toute la
question aujourd'hui c'est comment est
ce que justement les cosses
pourrissement 6 p
du gouvernement de londres tout en
restant avec une souveraine
c'est avec la touraine et peut-être que
la solution sera d'ailleurs le
le fait que les écossais majoritairement
non ouais
ne pas quitter la couronne britannique
de
reprendre une indépendance quand même
revenir dans l'union européenne et ça va
être un décès un des gros dossiers
intérieurs que
la reine et le prince charles ou avoir à
gérer
dans le limite
des fonctions qui sont les leurs au plan
constitutionnel
on pourrait imaginer un entre deux en
fait un pays à la fois rattachait alors
bref pluie parce que les plupart ont
déjà quasiment après ministre
écossais qui n'a pas les
deux pas de diplomatie et que ce n ya
pas de mai mais on peut imaginer un
effectivement un état indépendant et les
élections irlandaises ont montré aussi
que
l'irlande du nord pour la première fois
après avoir un peu
au ministre
[Musique]
des processus oui oui indépendantisme
le
la qualité est
les avantages monarchie vont
probablement permettre
de conserver et on voit la même chose en
espagne
le
certaines unités malgré les volontés de
d'indépendance gouvernement est ce qu'on
peut dire les cosses de l'irlande du
nord est ce que le royaume uni se délite
quelque part
[Musique]
au royaume uni a pas fun
ressemble à la france sur ce par
certains côtés mais mais en fait
[Musique]
le
localement
il ya eu depuis longtemps des velléités
d'autonomie
qui nous paraissent totalement étrangère
une région française mais même la corse
digérer la question c'est très différent
les écoles des écossais se sont beaucoup
plus francophile que les anglais les
écossais sont européens ils sont très
ouverts sur sur le pas ce qu'on dit la
vie il partage
la mer du nord et de
bassins pétroliers de
le rôle d'europe du nord c'est très
différent les mentalités en train a
causé à l'anglais ou un irlandais et un
anglais sont beaucoup plus
longs que ces questions là vont se poser
on ne sait pas peut aussi si les
britanniques comment les britanniques
gérons la chose en tout cas ce qui a
amorti le choc c'est c'est la monarchie
puisque
ils peuvent tout à fait rester
l'australie ou le canada en sont le sont
les exemples
peuvent rester avec ce même souverain
tout en acquérant des droits politiques
le pays souverain finalement il n'ya que
le
beghal tu n'as pas souci on va dire
2 l'indépendance oui parce que
parce qu'en fait
pays de galles a été digérée
[Musique]
j'ose pas capables nous dit de
particularismes locaux il
phases intéressantes mais
s'approche de brody mais il n'y a pas de
ses velléités politiques que par
l'irlande dont l'essor de gardons et
l'ecosse
avec un peu une
une recréation politique mais qui est
très fortement
si
on sort de glasgow d'edimbourg
[Musique]
alors l'avantagé aussi c'est que la
famille royale a toujours eu des
propriétés dans toutes les régions et
que même la mère de la reine étant
d'ascendance
l'irlandaise
ça a permis un rapport personnel
entre
d'écossé les irlandais et gallois et
la famille royale au delà même de la
question britannique
vise à suivre ce ce défilé à scie
musicale on peut le dire par rapport aux
banques pour qatar juger quand même
prononce outre musique
non monsieur c'est surtout différent
parce que nous on défile sur les champs
elysées et eux ils ont gardé une place
dédiée ce qui était le champ-de-mars
autrefois en france et qu'il dédiait aux
parades militaires
donc c'est plus statique
et j'en vois mieux effectivement le tout
autour de tours de cette place on a vu
on a vu ce balcon et des membres de
familles royales qui passaient une tête
puis qui ressortait qu'il rentrait c'est
prévu pour approprié noisy de dizaines
de minutes normalement devrait les voir
à ce moment-là apparaître jeu bien sûr
je lis vos commentaires si vous avez des
questions vous n'hésitez pas à nous les
poser on essaiera d'y répondre au mieux
comme d'habitude bien évidemment une
petite phase statique
quoi bon
il me l'a dit les différentes batailles
ont ils sont en sont identifiés par
cette petite marque sur le côté le géant
l'a8 et bleu clair voilà je crois que le
bloc faire saisir landais mais je me
trompe peut-être
donc en fait il y a
une
sous le même uniforme
apparent quitter l'uniforme
traditionnel de l'armée britannique doit
que cette veste rouge très
caractéristique il ya différents
régiments effectivement il ya des spots
voir les hives the world les
différentes composantes du royaume uni
sont eux-mêmes représentés au niveau
régimentaire elle m'avait français ne
verra pas les différences mais un essai
anglais
la verra et c'est aussi le moyen de
mettre en valeur les différents
régiments de la garde royale qui
rappelons le sont aussi des régiments
qui sont projetés
des régiments qui ont servi en
afghanistan c'est à dire que
on peut à la fois en étant dans un
régiment les gardes royale a les seins
en opérations extérieures et être
affectées après 1,1 en a la garde de
palais de la reine
c'est
vraies imprécations
entre le service
royal est
en commun des armées
aujourd'hui on peut parler de musique
aussi de lille
la roya minsk usées mois va changer dit
à la mort d'elizabeth ii oui puisque god
save the queen de veyrac deux sets the
king qui le thé vert du temps du père et
qui est comme on le sait une musique
française puisqu'elle est c'est une
musique elle est composée la cour de
louis xiv
donc
il ya un petit côté français et ils y
achètent chez la reine d'angleterre une
francophilie qui dépasse le fait qu'elle
parle parfaitement de klang
puisqu'elle se ses héritières des ducs
de normandie
elle est d'ailleurs
souveraine des îles anglo normandes
malheureusement le français se perd un
peu mais
qui ne sont pas formellement le royaume
uni et elle est là-bas chef de l'état en
tant que duchesse de normandie puisque
lors des traités qui ont permis le
rattachement de la normandie à royaume
de france on a oublié ses îles et à
jersey guernesey elle n'est pas
souveraine en tant que reine
d'angleterre mais en tant que de
duchesse de rentrer de leur mandat qui
est un de ses titres historiques qu'elle
a aussi on va vous laisser vivre à
bosser images avec cette musique qu'on
veut entendre bientôt
blake
m
[Musique]
compte tenu d'un saut up
à
un scotch tu de cala check up
escota cas pour les ventes aux indians à
chaud
[Musique]
gros
riches
[Musique]
le
continuez de suivre ce ce défilé
tropicaux lors de projets de la reine
tout devrait apparaître si quelques
minutes maintenant au au balcon c'est ce
sera le moment important de ce jubilé de
ce matin on se demander si sur le cheval
c'était pas le prince charles ça devrait
être lui mais comme vous pouvez le voir
avec ses oui on va dire d'erreurs mais
autrefois c'était la reine elle-même qui
il y a il ya dans cette cérémonie a
aussi un apport de
fidélité personnelle à la couronne pour
les
résumant de la garde royale qui sont mis
qui sont mis à l'honneur c'est assez
différent pour cela du 14 juillet
puisque en fait
c'est pas ce n'est pas une exposition de
l'armée britannique
dans tout ce qu'elle a deux
de remarquables mais c'est
un hommage rendu à la souveraine par la
garde royale mais par les résumant
d'élite
qui composent cette garde avec ce
décorum
inchangé depuis au moins un siècle
puisque chaque année la cérémonie prend
à peu près la même il n'y a pas cette
variation que nous connaissons par
exemple au 14 juillet où on met en avant
tel ou tel aliment chaque année
selon la volonté du chef de l'état
chef des armées
là on est sur un rituel immuable où
c'est à peu près le même la même
cérémonie c'est la même cérémonie chaque
année c'est quelque chose qui quittent
des kids qui ne pourrait on l'a dit la
reine d'angleterre est très attaché à
cette à cette cérémonie à ceux à cette
tradition si bien qu'avant c'était elle
qui était sur ce cheval justement tout à
fait
donc
l'atpu monter à cheval c'est elle même
qui
venait incarner ce
ce rapport très particulier
qui est celui de légitimité monarchique
ou
incarner son rôle de
chef des armées
et de shopping de couleurs et une sorte
de dire de serment
qui chaque année
viens
rappeler le
soldat de sa garde tél
leur serment de fidélité à son égard ces
deux
cet ami et n'oublions pas que la reine
elle-même entre pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale a conduit des
véhicules de l'armée a servi
réellement
sous les couleurs
britanniques à
l'époque son père rainier elle a tenu et
son père a tenu à ce qu'elle porte
l'uniforme auquel elle se sent
pleinement à sa place
au milieu de ses armées et c'est
effectivement ce fils et petit-fils eux
mêmes ont servi
dans les différents conflits
et au milieu des titres britanniques les
as excès comme on le disait une habitude
un héritage on est quand on fait partie
de la famille britannique on est obligé
on va dire de d'être d'être présent dans
l'est dans les forces armées finalement
oui
pour exercer dans l'ensemble des
monarchies européennes mais mais il ya
un rapport
bon maintenant avec la suspension du
service militaire en france on a moins
ce rapport mais il faut se souvenir que
giscard d'estaing encore combattu en
quarts en 44-45 et ces mêmes
le rapport qui l'unissaient au général
de gold qui
reconnaissait cette service jacques
chirac a lui même servir en
algérie
l'armée est un pouvoir régalien par
essence et
donc
il est très important pour les familles
royales de servir
alors alors mesurer leurs capacités dans
les rangs de
ces armes est
effectivement même si la reine ne peut
plus monter à cheval
elle est néanmoins là pour
pour apprécier cet hommage qui est celui
d'une fidélité de l'armée britannique et
des régiments de la garde royale
envers elle
c'est aussi l'incarnation c'est surtout
peut-être l'incarnation du lien armée
nation à la sauce britannique
voilà donc il n'y a rien d'exceptionnel
en fait c'est le même cérémonial que
tous les tous les ans mais nous le
regardons avec un oeil différent parce
que effectivement le jubilé est aussi
important que
et là on voit ce lien avec l'armé
que la clé de voûte le point capital de
ces cérémonies du jubilé
soit organisée autour de cette parade
militaire
n'est pas une sorte de
de grandes garden party ouverte où les
anglais non on reste autour de ce
cérémonial
qui fut celui la reine victoria qui fut
celui de
de l'empiré britannique et chaque année
les britanniques se souviennent
au travers de cette cérémonie voilà le
premier ministre qui se lève donc la
parade touche à sa fin et nous
spectateurs nos téléspectateurs au
pouvoir
voir ce qu'ils attendent tous c'est à
dire l'apparition de la reine
effectivement vous laisser vous revoir
ces images avec la musique qui en ce
moment sur ces images
[Musique]
combien de fois vous l'avez vu sur
l'image d'une société
middleton qui était commencée les
branches mais on les avait déjà vus il
ya 10 minutes à paraître petit à petit
les demandes elle pourra paraître
d'ailleurs une fois que ces discussions
seront terminées pour sa place à plein
clôture c'est un peu là
me alors il trouva tout sur le balcon
jusque là on voit prince charles en fait
elle a la main sessad qui sont même que
colonel
[Musique]
tiennent à
honorer les régiments donc
le patronage
[Musique]
bien sûr ils le
représente la reine et
qui elles mêmes de
[Musique]
ces conditions mais voilà donc toute la
famille royale ne sera pas sur le balcon
puisqu'une partie
et avec lui tout
seul
le rapport fusionnel entre l'armée
britannique
et la famille royale autour d'eux
de cette parade mais deux
et on les imagine assez peu remonté en
vitesse pour le brouillage
20 spécialistes mais en fait deux
l'allemand est effectivement il
il incarne la dimension militaire et
de la fonction royale
et sur la question
pendant des années c'est la règle même
qui préside à cette série
le terme
les spurs et ses images et cette musique
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
ouais
je crois
qu'avant
non
[Musique]
à
thomas
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
oh oh
oh
oh mais ce
poste
quick wood
n roses à la
main
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
on
parme
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah
ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
et
on
m
[Musique]
non
le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aa à aa
[Musique]
à
ouais
il
[Musique]
on
tous
[Musique]
pour
où
vous
m
[Musique]
lorsque
aux morts
oh
roj
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
roloson
risen
haut
il
[Musique]
oh
god
hand ball soldat ryan
jones
[Applaudissements]
quant aux
all
blacks
notre web
après on était des jeunes
pop
wakfu
[Musique]
salut
à
oh
[Musique]
ça va
oh
[Musique]
2 je connais
m
[Musique]
mais
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
apple
et
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la mer
[Musique]
il
à
[Musique]
ouais
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
à
oh
alors
voit sur ces images la rédaction
sur le bateau finalement de buckingham
palace elle est bien née elle est bel et
bien là elle est bien mais bel et bien
là et ont même une forme olympique
génial
edel est
voilà très attendu voilà sûrement
préparé ce mouvement de vente
d'activités tout est préparé mais
quand même faire 2,96
elle est au rendez vous
et les mêmes heureuse et radieuse donc
les britanniques sans rassurer la
monarchie tiendra encore
[Musique]
elle va mais on avait la fessée quelques
pas avec l'icann évidemment une telle
adversité plus pas pour montrer qu'elle
était encore guito savoir si c'était ça
aussi qui était important oui oui
surtout pas à brac
femi babafemi on voit
sourire
les changes
[Musique]
ça me change des f
réalisation de nous
la pays qui ne fournissent les images
les deux delà du balcon mais
effectivement ltd les gardes voilà
et là nous avons
pas ce soir et annule grille était au
défilé tout à l'heure avec le tourisme à
faire le bon choix
[Applaudissements]
donc là nous revoyons
la reine d'angleterre qui est des
leaders présents sur ce ballon
petit commentaire
on imagine les petits traits d'humour on
al impression qu avec annick des petites
blagues
oh
voilà 70 à 17h30 70 fois
effectivement sur 7 sur 7 quel est alors
oui auparavant elle était à cheval
quipourrait ne m'aimez la maintenant en
civil
sur le balcon fait elle a longtemps
présidé cette cérémonie
sur sur un cheval et en uniforme puisque
l attaque dimension militaire
toutes les fonctions politiques
militaires et religieuses puisque lé
chef
anglicane également symbole
effectivement merci beaucoup en tout cas
jérôme mainard d'avoir été avec nous
mêmes toujours nous faisons tout au long
de ce live je le rappelle l'ouvragé
beaucoup collaboré à la revue qui
s'appelle dynastie qui est ici vous
continuez de suivre bien évidemment le
jury de la reine qui va se poursuivre
ensuite la femme leur est devenue réelle
va la rejoindre mais c'était le grand
est le grand événement qu'on attendait
bien évidemment la reine d'angleterre
qui arrive sur ce balcon vous vous
pouvez continuer à suivre évidemment ce
ce grand événement merci une nouvelle
fois jérôme besnard d'avoir été si
beaucoup de votre invitation avec nous
et on va vous avant ça on va passer
quand même le petit message d' emmanuel
macron aussi qui a tenu à adresser un
message spécial à la reine d'angleterre
à la reine d'angleterre on va vous le
passez tous
[Musique]
l'europe
continue gay
pride
and friendship has been
seen surfer state visit france
longue saison minée vers fos
freedom we know you have the dead money
time i hope you are just dance in the
deep affection et admiration
cette people france a few
minutes of human life
ii the
golden state bynes out ou contre il se
trouve
michel bastos 3 9 mai prédécesseur rené
coty remind de cette triste anand
standing shoes and forever
you when we make my life time of
devotion lines for the dark days
général de gaulle
touristes ou welcome you in his hearing
comme sa présence sauce of wisdom for
leader
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
le soir
c
[Musique]
iggy pop
peut-être
assad
m
vous
[Musique]
donc
allez sur mac
[Musique]
façon tranchante
ss travers
[Applaudissements]
tu veux
hu
ça
[Musique]
il
j
[Musique]
de quoi
paris
[Musique]
je
et sur le fond
oui
m
[Musique]
z'artsup
bakou
[Musique]
hier
le tgb ii fabre
mme ashton
mexicaine
[Musique]
m
la bonne voie
à data
c'est
aux attentes et la paroisse
beaucoup